hey youtubers is charlie and just to get
things started in my game of thrones
season for countdown i wanted to do a
breakdown of all the best death since
season one it's totally in keeping with
the vogue our mogul esteem HBO has been
using to promote the series all week
every man must die if you're finding me
for the first time I'm just doing a
month-long countdown to the season 4
premiere with character breakdowns best
moments house histories and anything
else you guys want to see so feel free
to leave suggestions just getting
started i'll be doing about 2 videos a
week and then as we get closer to the
premiere i'll be able to like four
videos a week so be sure to subscribe
for dragons it's gonna be a lot of fun
now let's cue the bloodbath so we'll
start with season one and work our way
up to where we are now number one
starting things off with a good
beheading a patrol of nights Watchmen
meet the White Walkers beyond the wall
this was the very first scene of season
1 2 will pays the price for abandoning
his watch this was the last neck Ned
Stark's Valyrian greatsword ice with
touch 3g on is of actual use and kills
the wildling stiff to prevent him from
capturing brand kind of ironic given
what would happen later for Sir Hugh of
the Vale runs afoul of the mountains
Lance 5 Vardis Egan of the Vale runs
afoul of brawn and takes a trip down the
moon door 6 a random wine cellar tries
to poison Khaleesi Daenerys and gets
dragged dead 7 miseries gets the golden
crown he's a richly deserves 8 Robert
Baratheon dies after being poisoned and
then skewered by a boar 9 Khal Drogo
dies of an infection and then later from
a ritual gone horribly wrong 10 Oh Thor
of the Nights Watch dies then returns as
the white only to get killed again 11
Mirri Maz Duur is burned at the stake
for pretending to bring back Khal Drogo
12 jory cassel runs afoul of a
two-handed Jaime Lannister 13 Syrio
Forel dies at the hands of the
Kingsguard while defending himself with
a wooden sword 14 Ned Stark is beheaded
at the behest of new King Joffrey 15
septa Mordane head is put on a spike
also at the behest of new King Joffrey
16 arion StarClan's her very first kill
with her Valyrian blade needle now
begins season 2 17 maester Cressen
poisons himself in a botched attempt
Melisandre 18 bear waters and all of
Robert Baratheon's bastards are killed
by the gold cloaks 19 the High Septon is
killed by mob going after King Joffrey
they even ripped his arm off 20 the
Hound punches through a peasant's chest
trying to rape and kill Sansa 21 yarn is
killed by the gold cloaks trying to
capture Gendry 22 lomi green hands is
also killed by the gold cloaks looking
for again dree 23 Renly Baratheon is
killed by Melisandre smoke baby 24 the
tickler sir armory Lorch and the
Harrenhal guards are all killed by Jack
and hug are 25 Jon Snow is forced to
kill corn half an when t6 Gary in
danny's khalasar are murdered and
arrayed to steal the Dragons 27 the
members of the thirteen are murdered by
piatt 328 roderick a cell is be headed
by phien 29 the on murdered Billy and
Jack in place of bran and Rickon 30
maester Luwin is also murdered by the
end 31 math.oc words and almost anyone
on board a boat during the Battle of
Blackwater 32 I appre is roasted by
danny's dragons now we entered season 3
33 poster Tully died off-screen but his
funeral set the tone for the season 34
the leaders of the second son's are
beheaded for plotting against Danny 35
beric Dondarrion is killed by the hound
then brought back 36 Lord Commander
Jorah Mormont is killed in a Night's
Watch revolt 37 old Craster is also
murdered by the same renegade night's
watchman 38 Ross is murdered by Joffrey
with his crossbow 39 kraznys is roasted
by drogon 40 Jon Snow kills a rel after
he warped into his hawk 41 Rickard
Karstark is beheaded by Robb Stark 42
Samwell kills a white Walker with
dragonglass now begins the red wedding
43 lisa stark Robb Stark joy you spray
Catelyn Stark grey wind and the
remainders of the stark army are all
berger by the phrase and finally 43 Aria
kills one of the fray soldiers after he
brags about said red wedding feel free
to leave a comment with any big death
you think I skipped remember my next
video in my game of thrones season for
countdown will post next week depending
on whether or not I do any Oscar videos
that'll probably be on Monday be sure to
subscribe to get everything it'll need
to be a Q&A video or maybe a winds of
winter video you can let me know which
you'd prefer right now click here to get
my break down to the last trailer and
click here to learn all about my south
park stick of truth giveaway thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you